here's what the test location table
method looks like first we grab a
reference to a writable database because
we'll be modifying the database then we
create content values for a row of
location data using the function within
tests utilities then we insert that
content values object into the location
table the return value of the insert
statement should be the row ID if it's
negative 1 we know the insertion failed
so we assert that then we query the
location table and pass null for all the
parameters to get a default query of all
table rows and columns since we want to
precisely verify that our database only
contains our inserted record the query
will return a cursor and we assert if we
cannot move it to the first row finally
we call validate current record from the
tests utilities to validate that the
query returned the correct record
validate current record grabs a set of
value pairs from the content values we
inserted it then iterates through them
using cursor get column index to get the
index of each column in the record set
by name we need the column index to get
data from the cursor note the
projections are always returned in order
so if we specify a projection we can
safely use the indices from our
projection array without having to look
them up like this let's go back to our
test we check to make sure that the
database has only one record by making
sure it move to next fails then we close
the cursor in database we don't leak
resources finally we return the location
row ID let's run the test and see what
happens and the test pass woohoo only
one more test to write